well her Legacy is of course her Talent
her authenticity
her ability to share care and make a
difference in the world especially in
the world of cancer which is something
that she
she learned to have to live with I think
she showed that you could be all of the
above you know you could be the full
package to be a good wife you could be a
good mother it could be an amazing
Superstar and you could be an icon of
philanthropy
ladies
[Music]
how did you learn about Olivia passing
away one of my mutual friends called me
and told me and I am I was with some of
our mutual friends yesterday at a little
party I had here and we were talking
about her and talking about how she
hadn't been answering our texts and we
all kind of felt that
something was happening I mean she's had
metastasized cancer I mean nobody lives
as long as she did
she broke all you know all the rules of
science I mean she just kept going and
going and going and you know I I
honestly I saw her pre-covered and I
thought that was going to be the last
time I'd see her so she went up and then
she went down
and up and down but what she did have
constantly which was really
so sad and so hard was this paint
terrible pain
so you know I think they managed her
pain and she just kept going and going
until you know until she
you know it took over
so she really fought I mean you know she
was a fighter she was beyond a fighter
she she always said she was a thriver
that was her word not a Survivor a
thriver
and I think you know
she taught me and everyone I know so
much about living with
and passing with cancer I mean we're all
going to go one day
but you kind of go oh I'm so terrified
I'm terrified I'm angry I'm I'm gonna
isolate I'm not gonna let anyone know
I'm going to be all alone and go through
it or do you do what she did and just be
brave and just say hey I'm going through
something a lot of people go through and
can't talk about and won't talk about
and I have a voice and I'm going to help
people as best I can I actually went to
a cancer hospital in Melbourne I mean
she built a hospital for cancer
I mean she was the most amazing woman
which all she cared about you know even
in her final years when I'd go and see
her all she wanted to know is what I was
doing are you happy what's going on in
your life how are your kids how's this
how's that you know she just
were talking about she thrived and she
lived and she appreciated nature and she
appreciated
close friends and she
she just lived a full and
um
sort of spiritual life living
you know I I last time I saw her
um
you know she got the day wrong and we
arrived the day before or something and
she was in bed
and I was there with my sister she knew
that I'd driven like two hours two and a
half hours to come and find her and it's
with my sisters from England
bless her she gets out of bed
somehow managed to get dressed I don't
know how somehow goes out on a you know
like walk around
and sits down and talks to us for 20
minutes and you know and and just
so loving and so present and so
wonderful and and and seemingly really
happy to see us and at the same time I
was looking at her going
I don't think I'm ever going to see you
again you know and um she just sat out
there she said look at this bird so
listen to the look at the hummingbirds
you know look at the dogs look at the
horses
so beautiful you know and she was just
kind of blissing out on the fact that
she was alive in nature and that she
wanted to see what was good in the world
in in a sense taking it all in because
she knew the end was near yeah
[Music]
these are a couple of pictures that we
took as I left when I thought that I may
never see her again she was
um she was on a walker at that time and
she would see it's very very thin but
she came back from this one
and then and then you know it got bad
again but she uh
she always had a smile on her face she
never felt sorry for herself I've no I
never saw her get angry or
um
grumpy or depressed
I'm sure she must have all human beings
do but I've never saw it ever
[Music]
feel over here right now that's you know
I I know you should write up there
staring at me
to be ridiculous you don't stop crying
you silly idiot
[Music]
foreign